ist burnout eigentlich eine echte
krankheit burnout oft stellt man sich
das so vor man arbeitet und arbeitet
überarbeitet sich bis man irgendwann
zusammenbricht und gar nichts mehr geht
ausgebrannt ende gelände aber burnout
fängt viel früher an burnout beschreibt
ein breites spektrum an psychischen
problemen im zusammenhang mit beruf und
arbeit
doch es gibt bisher keine eindeutige
medizinische definition von burnout
streng genommen muss man also die frage
ist burnout eine echte krankheit
definitionsgemäß mit nein beantworten
allerdings gibt es burnout symptome über
die sich experten einig sind
dazu zählen erstens extreme emotionale
erschöpfung
man fühlt sich müde ausgelaugt
überarbeitet zweitens distanzierung oder
entfremdung und kann sich mit seiner
arbeit nicht mehr identifizieren und ist
gefühlt taub wird vielleicht zynisch und
drittens leistungsabfall und man wird
schlechter dem was zu tun ist
aber wo ist die grenze zwischen burnout
und ganz normal im stress die frage muss
lauten wo ist die grenze zwischen
normalem stress und gefährlichem
chronischen stress die verläuft fließend
als folge von chronischem stress
schleicht sich langsam an aber für die
betroffenen kann es durchaus plötzlich
erscheinen wenn man sich der symptome
nicht rechtzeitig bewusst wird oder wenn
man eigentlich spaß an seiner arbeit hat
spaß siege arbeit ist zwar zunächst
gesünder für die psyche verleitet
allerdings zur überarbeitung und
verpflichtungen und leistungsdruck
bestehen ja trotzdem
chronischer stress kann viele folgen
haben zimmer nur ein paar auf
schlafstörungen und angstzuständen
muskulärer beschwerden geschwächtes
immunsystem bluthochdruck langfristig
steigt das risiko für
herz-kreislauf-erkrankungen übergewicht
depressionen und burnout
wo ist die grenze zwischen burnout und
depression burnout bezieht sich auf
einen beruflichen kontext depression
betrifft er alle lebensbereiche
doch tatsächlich sind typische
burnout-symptome extremer erschöpfung
anteils losigkeit als abfall
ebenfalls typisch für eine depression
für viele experten ist burnout als
vorstufe zur depression zu verstehen
manche waren davor dass hinter vielen
börner diagnosen bereits eine depression
stecken könnte vielleicht auch eine
angststörung oder das chronische fatigue
syndrom bei dem betroffene unter
extremer anhaltende erschöpfung leiden
burnout ist aber für manche leichter zu
akzeptieren als depression burnout
klingt nach einem leistungsträger die es
übertrieben hat depressionen nach einem
schwachen gemüter sogar verlierer
das ist nicht nur falsch sondern
gefährlich diagnostiziert man bernard
voreilig könnte es dazu führen dass
schwerwiegendere probleme nicht erkannt
und entsprechend behandelt werden
doch wer bekommt am ehesten burnout
manager lehrer können es auch schüler
bekommt gibt es so was wie ein
mindestalter für burnout kann
prinzipiell jeden treffen
doch die wahrscheinlichkeit ist bei
manchen höher als bei anderen frauen
sind wie bei depressionen auch öfter
betroffen als männer und menschen unter
30 sind seltener betroffen als ältere
aber es kann auch schüler und
studierende treffen selbst eltern da ist
es ein besonders großes tabu dabei ist
das sich kümmern um andere menschen
emotional besonders belastend gefährdet
sind daher auch kranken- und
altenpfleger ärzte sozialarbeiter oder
lehrer
doch was ist jetzt die ursache würde ich
mir selbst in stress auf liegt es in
meinen arbeitsbedingungen oder bestimmt
meine gene wie ich mit stress umgehen
die antwort ist alles davon spielt eine
rolle und zwar gleichzeitig zu den
äußeren faktoren gehören nicht nur
arbeitsbedingungen sondern zum beispiel
auch soziale rückhalt im privaten
zusammen mit persönlichkeitsmerkmalen
und genetischen faktoren beeinflusst
sich alles gegenseitig
wenn zwei menschen dieselbe arbeit
machen für eine gut damit klar kommt der
andere aber ein burnout erleidet hilft
es nicht zu sagen
reißt dich mal zusammen dein kollege
kommt doch auch damit klar
genau wie ich jemand durch passivrauchen
lungenkrebs erleiden kann während jemand
anderes mit 80 jahren noch fröhlich vor
sich hin qualmt sind auch psychische
krankheiten von mehreren dingen abhängig
aber warum werden psychische beschwerden
scheinbar immer häufiger das fragt sich
auch die wissenschaft und kommt zu dem
schluss sie werden nicht wirklich
häufiger
doch da immer mehr psychische
erkrankungen erforscht verstanden und
definiert werden werden sie auch
häufiger diagnostiziert ausserdem suchen
sich menschen häufiger professionelle
hilfe während man früher dass er mit
sich selbst ausgemacht hat und was kann
man jetzt gegen börner tun wenn ihr euch
bei bedenken euren hausarzt oder eure
hausärztin die können euch an
spezialisten weiterleiten
und wenn es euch seelisch nicht gut geht
und ihr niemanden zum reden habt so gibt
es zum beispiel die telefonseelsorge die
übrigens nicht nur übers telefon sondern
auch online und in vielen städten vor
ort für euch da es infos in der video
beschreibung der burnout noch keine
psychische erkrankung ist sondern eine
warnung einer zu entwickeln können wir
es auch positiv sehen und dankbar sein
für diese warnung doch was euch hilft
seines mehr pausen eine zeitweilige
freistellung von der arbeit oder
achtsamkeit übungen
das kann bei jedem unterschiedlich sein
ich kann euch an dieser stelle nur
erzählen wie ich damit umgehe
bei mir kam dieses jahr beruflich viel
erfreuliches zusammen bei laptops ich
habe mein erstes buch geschrieben
aber ich habe viel zu viel gearbeitet
jedes wochenende und sehr oft nachts ich
hatte keine zeit für familie freunde
sport auf der gass sich sogar das beste
ich fragte mich ob ich vielleicht kurz
vor einem burn out stehe aber ich hatte
ja keine zeit mich zu informieren
da dachte ich ich mache einfach in
meinem video sogar nicht die arbeit und
persönliches anliegen verbinden ich
fuchs momentan fühle ich mich auf jeden
fall erschöpft sehr sogar
das wäre ja dann schon mal ein burn out
symptome aber zum glück fühle ich mich
bei der arbeit noch weder distanziert
noch demotiviert doch ich muss er jetzt
nicht warten bis der burnout kommt dann
ja schon vorher konsequenzen ziehen
deswegen macht miley jetzt erstmal
winterpause und wenn der youtube
algorithmus angeblich sagt bewusst jede
woche ein video hochladen
dann sage ich jetzt einfach [ __ ] you
algorithmus es gibt wichtigeres als dich
ich bin optimistisch dass ich dieses mal
noch gesund davon komme und im neuen
jahr sehen wir uns dann wieder mit
aufgeladenen batterien und darauf freue
ich mich bis dahin passt auf euch auf
und bleibt sicher